avec nous dans la matinale de france s
agit-il selon vous d'une opération
communication
alors oui ce matin magali vous l'avez
dit on va parler de l'ena 7e
prestigieuse école chargé de former
l'élite de la nation
petit rappel historique tout de même
pour nos téléspectateurs parce que c'est
toujours bien vous savez de se
rafraîchir la mémoire sur nos florent il
en reste tellement peu alors l'ena qui
signifie l'école nationale
d'administration a été créé un autre top
45 1 au sortir de la seconde guerre
mondiale par le gouvernement provisoire
présidé par le général de gaulle est
piloté par michel debré alors quel est
le rôle de lena et bien c'était c'était
je dis bien de démocratiser le
recrutement des hauts fonctionnaires
d'état pour fournir à ce pays une élite
capable d'administrer la nation par une
haute administration qui je voue la
corde bien humblement n'est plus en
odeur de sainteté depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
voilà en somme le postulat originel de
l'ena pavé de bonnes intentions pour
mener le pays emmanuel macron pris au
piège d'une véritable bérézina politique
dont il est le seul responsable se
retrouve acculé par quoi avec par la
présidentielle qui approche
alors il tente un coup politique
emmanuel macron voulant déboulonner les
nattes donc qu'il est lui même issu
promotion senghor 2004 alors le chef de
l'état gracieux supprimer l'ena 40
en réalité on supprime pas les noms on
ne le remplace pas le supprime
et nous aurons à la droit à la place un
obscur institut du service public
alors ce matin ils ont essayé de
comprendre que c'est une très très
mauvaise idée sans fondement mais c'est
aussi la disparition pure et simple il
faut le dire deux fleurons de notre pays
qui est aussi participé au rayonnement
de la france à l'étranger
alors cette décision répond peut-être à
la culture web d'emmanuel macron qui
veut bouter l'énarchie française pour
produire peut-être à la place une armée
de celio de manager de lead managers de
top managers voire de community manager
pour la start-up des jeunes jouent au
baby foot hand dans un open space entre
2d créé trois projets de loi ouais
pourquoi selon vous est ce que c'est une
mauvaise idée de supprimer les nains
alors bien en fait c'est le fruit de
plusieurs mauvaises idées vous l'avez
dit simultanées qui répondent à deux
problème majeur d'une part la totale des
collections des manuels macro combinée à
une stratégie politique déplorable 2
d'instruction alors première mauvaise
idée un emmanuel macron effet cette
promesse après la crise et gilet jaune
souvenez vous mais moi je me pose la
question depuis cette annonce à quel
moment les gilets jaunes ont demandé la
suppression l'ena je n'ai pas vu dans
les manifs et j'en ai fait beaucoup des
manifestations des pancartes en 4 par 3
ou envoyer crillon veut la suppression
de l'ena à balai n'a en moins qui gilet
jaune peut-elle des demandes et dans les
cahiers de doléances vous savez magali
en tasse et aux archives départementales
gouvernement sont n'a jamais lu en
réalité les gilet jaune n'ont jamais
jamais demandé la suppression l'ena
deuxième mauvaise idée y at il une
volonté je me pose la question de faire
de l'ena le bouc émissaire de tous les
blocages et de toutes les thromboses
française
si tel est le cas c'est une erreur très
grosse ya même si la haute
administration française est en partie
responsable de la logistique
désastreuses pour faire face à la crise
sanitaire
en réalité le fond du problème il est là
l'ena n'est pas le noeud gordien de la
trahison des élites dans ce pays
la vraie fracture entre nos élites et
les français provient d'une obsession
obstinément mondialiste qui tronçonnent
la france en la vendant au kilo par une
élite qui a largué les amarres dérives
de la nation car l'état et la haute
administration n'ont pas failli tout
seul dans cette crise sanitaire
mais si notre classe politique dans son
ensemble depuis 30 ans qui a
scrupuleusement des membres est découpée
et dépouillé l'été on en a déjà parlé
ici
en somme la nation doit mourir les
frontières doivent être effacés poussé
par cette idéologie destructrice depuis
maastricht ya aussi qu'il ya aussi
gangrené l'ena au passage et dernière
troisième mauvaise idée et c'est là le
loin la plus inquiétante ces tirs c'est
le bougisme alors je m'explique qu'est
ce que c'est le bougisme ce mot barbare
ben comme emmanuel macron finalement il
constate que toutes ces initiatives
contre la coved échoue lamentablement
qu'il n'ira pas au bout de ses réformes
structurelles suivez mon regard vers
bruxelles eh bien il lui reste le coût
de la communication politique le bien
nommé bougisme c'est l'histoire de la
promesse tenue qui ne sert absolument à
rien il n'y a t'il pas tout de même
nicolas un souci d'équilibré ou de
diversité pour enfin accéder à la haute
administration avec cette suppression de
l'ena ben non car anaïs politique d'
emmanuel macron est mauvaise ou à minima
biaisé car la république ce n'est pas
l'égalitarisme la république c'est la
méritocratie pleine et entière
c'est le fait en fait de s'extraire de
sa condition sociale grâce à la nation
si on est méritant par son travail et sa
détermination à réussir quel que soit
son milieu
et puis la république on le dit très peu
finalement 1 s'est bâtie autour de deux
idées majeures la patrie d'un côté et le
peuple qui ont été remplacés par quad et
je vous le donne en mille par l'économie
et le marché et nos élites bien entendu
ont opéré ce basculement très
inégalitaire ena ou pas ajoutons que si
l'aîné n'a pas empêché finalement par un
manque diversité elle a aussi produit
tympans 80 ans depuis 45 une élite dans
certains de ses membres venaient du
peuple situé du moins sa mission
républicaine dès le début alors couper
la tête de l'ena pour réduire les
inégalités ne sert strictement à rien si
un grand plan marshall de refonte pour
l'éducation nationale n'est pas
entrepris très rapidement car
aujourd'hui c'est une grosse machine
public qui produit de l'échec de la
frustration du ressentiment et regardez
d'ailleurs le classement pisa c'est
absolument catastrophique car les
français les plus aisés ont écarté leurs
enfants de l'enseignement public pour
les met dans le privé en france ou à
l'étranger poursuivre leurs études en
finalement en conclusion en réalité la
session n'hésitent-elles est absolument
partout
elle n'est pas propre à la fabrique de
technocrates de l'ena car les promesse
républicaine est devenu un mensonge pour
la majorité des français
abandonné par une méritocratie qui a été
congédié et certains énarque aime à
répéter qu'ils aiment à répéter je cite
je veux bien initier les français il ne
faut pas me demander de vivre avec est
bien avec cette suppression charge
énarque vous voilà de retour à la merci
à la maison merci qui merci emmanuel
macron et merci nicolas vidal prochain
les vitaux à la semaine prochaine on
parlera de faut-il supprimer sciences po
peut-être on verra allez allez à la
semaine prochaine